Speaker 1: So there's a lot of liars in politics
and there's a lot of terrible people in politics,
and sometimes they're the same people, the
terrible people also happen to be really big
liars. And I believe that Florida Republican
Governor Ron DeSantis is one of those bad
people who is also a liar. Yesterday, I played
a clip for you, which we are going to look at
again today, in which Rhonda Santurce
held some big press conference at which
he announced that if a business tries
to require sorry, if if a Florida state
government agency tries to require a vaccination
of an employee, they will be fined 5000 dollars.
At this very event. Some guy came to the lectern,
stood behind the seal of the Florida governor
and said, the vaccine changes your RNA. Now, I'm
going to play it for you. If you're watching,
you will notice dissent is definitely looks like
he heard it. He seems to get a little bit of a
not super comfortable look on his face when it's
said because it doesn't look great to have such
unhinged, unscientific anti back statements said.
When you're trying to make the case we're not anti
vaccine, we're just pro freedom. Well, the vaccine
changes. Your MRSA is pretty bad or your RNA,
I think he said so. It does seem as though
DeSantis heard it. All right. Let's take
a look here. Here's a reminder of the clip.
Speaker 4: The vaccine changes your RNA. So
for me, that's a problem. So I'm here with you
folks. We don't want to have the vaccine. It's
it's about our freedom and liberty.
Speaker 1: So my interpretation is that
dissent is clearly seems to be reacting to the
wacky nonsense that that guy is saying about the
vaccine changes your RNA. There is a new report.
Now, a lot of people said rightly, why didn't why
didn't he go up to the lectern and immediately
say that's not true? That would have been the
responsible thing to do. There is now a report
that Ron DeSantis says he just didn't hear it. He
just didn't hear it. Guys, DeSantis denies hearing
false comment that covid vaccine alters RNA.
Governor Ronda Santurce on Tuesday denied
hearing a false comment that the covid-19
vaccine changes human RNA even though he was
standing next to the person when he made it.
Honestly, I don't even remember him saying
that. So it's not anything I've said.
I think the data is clear. You're much
less likely to be hospitalized or die
if you are vaccinated. The guy who said it
is dearest friend, a 22 year old member of
the Gainesville workforce and a plaintiff in
a lawsuit against the city's vaccine mandate.
He spoke at the event at which the governor
said he would find local government leaders
who require workers to get vaccinated. The vaccine
changes your RNA and Rhonda Santurce is saying,
I just didn't hear it. Guys, I'm going to play it
once more for you. I get that the audio component
of this is less telling. But if you're watching
the video, DeSantis is listening to the guy.
He's two feet away from the guy. He seems to
look a little sick to his stomach when he hears
this. But the claim is I didn't hear it.
Speaker 4: The vaccine changes your RNA.
So for me, that's a problem. So I'm here with
you folks. We don't want to have the vaccine.
It's it's about our freedom and
liberty. It's not about the vaccine.
Speaker 1: So I don't believe for a second that
Rhonda Santurce didn't hear it. We wondered
yesterday, why is this guy not contradicting what
is being said by these people? And obviously,
the most simple explanation is not he didn't hear
it. He was two feet away listening and visually
reacted to it. The most simple explanation is this
is an event at which the idea is to just make it
overwhelmingly clear vaccine mandates are bad and
it would not be conducive to that to interrupt and
say, actually, that's not true, but the mandates
are still bad and bla bla bla bla bla. So taking
the I just didn't hear it approach Ron DeSantis,
one of the absolute worst governors in the country
right now. Do you believe he didn't hear it?
I don't believe it for a second, my friends